in the US impeachment managers with the
House of Representatives have filed a
brief laying out their arguments for the
charges against President Donald Trump
now the Senate trial has formally begun
with opening statements expected on
Tuesday in their briefing document the
Democrats say Trump abandoned his oath
and must be removed from office to
safeguard the integrity of the 2020
election well the White House released a
statement from Trump in response saying
that the articles of impeachment
submitted by House Democrats are a
dangerous attack on the right of the
American people to freely choose their
president this is a brazen and a lawful
attempt to overturn the results of the
2016 election and interfere with the
20/20 election now just months away
Harry Lisbeth is a former US attorney
and host of talking feds podcast he says
Trump's response to this summons was
unsurprising and that it'll be at least
two weeks until there's a vote on
whether witnesses are called there's
really not much in the answer to the
summons that we haven't be heard before
including its pugnacious tone he they
really strike out at the house managers
for daring to have initiated this
process which they try to portray as
something of a constitutional hijacking
so it's a very aggressive tone but no
more or less than we've heard from them
in recent months so it will be after
these opening statements which are that
makes them seem maybe shorter than they
are that'll be two weeks of proceedings
at that point by far the majority of the
republican-controlled Senate would would
love to if they could just shut it down
and say we've heard enough but there are
three or four or five Republicans who
may feel otherwise and it is after all a
pretty compelling position if there's
important testimony out there why not
hear it
so the Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
may not be able to prevent a motion to
hear some testimony and if you were
gauging the kind of
behind-the-scenes movement over the last
week you would say that it seems to be
moving in the direction of at least
having some witnesses there are a few
so-called moderate Republicans who seem
in favor of it and they themselves are
buffeted by political winds from
districts where it's not so
monolithically for Trump and they need
to portray themselves as being not in
lockstep with a very unpopular president
other than within the Republican Party